tonight russia says nato's expansion is
a threat to its security talks between
russia and the nato military alliance
ended today with no clear promises that
an armed conflict can be avoided in
europe's backyard the two sides are
trying to find common ground as concerns
grow that russia is preparing a military
invasion of ukraine moscow has already
positioned a hundred thousand troops
along its border with ukraine and nato
is calling for them to be pulled back
russia wants written guarantees that
ukraine will never join nato but nato
says that's up to ukraine
here's nato chief yen stoltenberg's
assessment of today's meeting
this was not an easy discussion
we have a very serious
and direct exchange
on the situation in and around ukraine
and the implications for european
security
there are significant differences
between nato allies
and russia on these issues
our differences will not be easy to
bridge
but it is a positive sign
that all nato allies anderson sat down
around the same table and engaged on
substantive topics
well following the talks russia's deputy
foreign minister alexander grushko
assertions that the expansion of nato is
a threat to russia
the main task of nato's policy and
military deployment is to deter russia
and enormous resources are being
allocated for this purpose
today many countries have joined nato
and their territories are obviously used
as the basis for projecting power
against russia at strategic depth
that seriously worsens our security and
creates an unacceptable risk for us
for more now i'm joined by lyanna fix
she's with the german marshall fund of
the united states her specialty nato
russia relations leona it's good to have
you on the program
both sides sat down and talked today but
essentially their positions have not
changed so did did anyone
achieve
the
seemingly impossible of moving the
middle needle at all today
i think it was good that the talks took
place
but then again it's better than a
military escalation as you said the
positions are weedy or seem to be
irreconcilable at the moment there is
however room for maneuver when it comes
to certain security issues in europe
when it comes to the stationing of
missiles for instance that is something
where nato signaled it could discuss
this further with russia but we have to
wait what will be the response from
moscow next week after these talks and
do you think with nato saying that it is
willing to to talk about arms control
and missile deployments do you think
that's enough to keep negotiations going
i think everyone hopes it is enough but
no one including the russian delegation
at the moment really knows it seems that
decision making in moscow at the moment
is really focused on the russian
president and that only when his
diplomats come back from the talks he
will take a decision on whether this is
enough what they delivered or whether it
is not enough and a military escalation
might be the path to go for russia
and russia if you look at the whole
story here we've got russia basically
forcing nato
to the negotiating table by putting a
hundred thousand troops at its border
with ukraine
do you think russia is even interested
in a diplomatic solution
i think they're trying to really put
everything on the table to get
concessions and again it is surprising
where suddenly these grievances that
russia had for many many years and has
voiced for many many years now have to
be resolved within weeks or months and
there has been no obvious trigger this
is a crisis which is created by the
russian side
but again at the moment it is almost
impossible to say whether the
the the room for maneuver that was found
will be enough or which steps russia
will take
and what do you think if push comes to
shove here if we see
russia invade ukraine
can you imagine the u.s and nato
actually going to war over ukraine with
russia
no absolutely not and this is something
which has already been made very clear
both for the united states and europe
that
no one will be militarily involved in an
escalation so that is not something to
be concerned about but it there is
something to be concerned about which is
really the security of ukraine which is
really russia's posturing and imperial
posturing in the neighborhood and the
united states and europe have outlined
very clearly what the consequences will
be of such
such a russian intervention
sanctions um support for ukraine support
for eastern nato member states the
question really is if that is enough of
a deterrence to bring
moscow
back to the negotiation table in the
coming weeks
and isn't russia what russia doing right
now isn't it really putting the security
situation for all of europe into
question with its actions right now i
mean it is
it is putting doubt into the minds of
leaders at nato
and across europe right now isn't it
well there might be some short-term
tactical gains for russia with the
approach that pursues right now but
there will definitely be long-term
strategic losses
which is the position of finland and
sweden for instance which already have
signaled that they will independently
decide whether they plan to join nato or
not at some point in the future
it is also
you can also see signs in eastern
european countries which demand more
reassurance measures more troops in
their countries so again this russian
posturing is creating an even greater
backlash in europe and by those
countries who feel threatened
liana fix with the german marshall fund
of the united states we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
i'm now joined by our correspondent
terry schultz in brussels she is
following the talks for us good evening
to you terry
so what are your sources telling you how
did these talks go today
brent the amount of relief that we saw
among nato officials after this meeting
took place just goes to show how low
expectations were and how big the
concerns were that they might not take
place at all remember the russians had
threatened to possibly not even show up
for these talks if they didn't feel like
the monday meeting with the united
states and geneva went well so the very
fact that they held these talks that the
russians stayed at the table even longer
than expected the meeting went on about
an hour longer than we had been told to
expect that all added up to a good sign
for nato that the russians were actually
or may actually be willing to discuss
these issues
we heard the russian negotiator after
those talks with the u.s on monday say
that ukraine can never ever be allowed
to join nato so where where's the room
then for negotiation on that
on that there isn't any room for
negotiation and the russians are fully
aware of that even as they say it
this is something that doesn't just
involve ukraine it also would
involve any other country wanting to
join nato in the future georgia of
course is on that list and both ukraine
and georgia have been promised that they
will be allowed to join nato this really
isn't something that nato is even going
to consider and and the russians know
that fully well they just want to sort
of put
put their red lines very very starkly
laid out and then perhaps walking back
from from that makes them look like
they're being reasonable but this is
truly an issue in which there's no
discussion
dw's brussels team spoke to britain's
junior foreign minister today james
cleverley would you take a listen to
part of what he told us
i and others made it very clear
that an invasion of ukraine would be a
terrible strategic mistake that there
would be repercussions
and that there is a high likelihood
that russia will be drawn into a
quagmire a long-standing and painful
conflict that would see russians lose
their lives and ukrainians lose their
lives this is in no one's interest
in no one's interest so how real is
the possibility of a military conflict
terry if russia were to invade ukraine
what would a nato response look like do
we know
well ukraine isn't a nato member as is
also clear and so nato as an alliance is
not ever going to go defend ukraine but
uh countries bilaterally the united
states has made it clear that it would
not stand idly by if russia were to
invade ukraine other nato allies would
also provide support and have been
providing support to ukraine
they've been selling lethal military
equipment they've been training
ukrainian forces and one analyst i spoke
with jim townsend even believes that the
u.s should step up this aid should
actually put more u.s soldiers in
ukraine to for for training purposes
just to warn the russians that they
better not step over that line because
of course you take aim in an american
and and then it's all over so truly
there are discussions about what more to
do to bolster ukraine but there wouldn't
ever be a nato response at 30 at 30
allies i want you to take a listen also
to what the u.s deputy
deputy secretary of state wendy sherman
said today after the talks with nato and
russia concluded
the united states and our nato allies
were united in our responses to deputy
foreign minister gushko and deputy
minister of defense afoman
and their comments including when it
comes to certain core russian proposals
that are simply non-starters
together the united states and our nato
allies made clear we will not slam the
door shut
on nato's open door policy a policy that
has always been central to the nato
alliance
now terry you know as we were saying
there were separate talks on monday
between the u.s and russia
should we read any t anything into that
i mean is the u.s fully in lockstep with
nato or is russia trying to play these
two off of each other
well remember brent that when the the
talk about having these discussions
first came up the europeans absolutely
did not want the us and russia to hold
bilateral talks that was in a demand of
the kremlin and it was something that
the europeans felt weakened their
negotiating position now the united
states did ultimately agree to hold
those bilateral meetings in geneva but
you've seen just this enormous outreach
to the europeans by wendy sherman and by
other u.s officials to keep talking to
the europeans right up until the last
minute they walked into those bilateral
talks then wendy sherman came to
brussels yesterday and spent all day
debriefing nato allies debriefing
european union officials meeting with
the top leadership in the eu as well as
in nato even before heading into these
nato-russia talks now so the u.s is
definitely trying to keep true to its
word that it won't discuss anything
about europe without europe anything
about ukraine without ukraine
we've just had four years of the trump
administration wanting to disengage
with nato getting if you will chummy
with russia has that left any permanent
scars at nato
i think it has and and just this this uh
outreach i mean honestly
almost too much outreach it sometimes
seemed like you know more than a hundred
meetings or something like this this is
partly a legacy of the trump
administration where the europeans had
no clue um from day to day except by
looking at twitter what the u.s policy
might be and the biden administration is
very much trying to make up for that and
keep the europeans on board and keep the
europeans reassured that's in the u.s
interest
as well as the europeans interest so
yeah i think that all of this
communication is partly a legacy of the
trump administration both for the u.s
benefit and for the europeans as well
dw's terry schultz with the ladies
tonight from brussels as always terry
thank you
on thursday russian diplomats will meet
with the organization for security and
cooperation in europe the ofce a third
day that will wrap up this week's
attempts at finding a diplomatic
solution to this crisis
all of this talking may sound like
background noise for people who are
living in eastern ukraine for nearly
eight years ukrainian forces have been
fighting a russian-backed separatist
insurgency a conflict that has cost more
than 14 thousand lives now with a
hundred thousand combat ready russian
troops just over the border people live
in fear of an imminent invasion
dw correspondent nick connolly traveled
to the front line city of donetsk to
talk about the prospects for
de-escalation
just before the shooting starts you see
the cats and dogs taking cover it's like
they can feel it's coming
here on the front lines near donetsk
gunfire and shelling are part of
everyday life and have been for the past
eight years for the stray animals the
ukrainian soldiers and the few civilians
left
there's still people living there and
over there beyond that there's no one
just the front line
most of those left are elderly and have
nowhere else to
go russian-backed separatists are only a
few hundred meters away from these
ukrainian positions close enough to
watch each other cooking or chopping
firewood
we arrived just a matter of minutes
after the last exchange of fire
the ukrainians say both sniper activity
and drone attacks have spiked in recent
weeks
as the world tries to second guess
vladimir putin's troop build up on
ukraine's borders the soldiers here
understand that they would likely be the
first to bear the brunt of an invasion
of course we're following the news
closely but whatever happens our army is
in much better shape than in 2014.
russia would face a lot more resistance
it's the civilians out there who are
getting really nervous
it
was
you see that power line our troops are
30 meters behind it they managed to push
their positions forward a bit
when we first met katya and her children
in 2017 the fighting was even closer
back then the front line started where
her garden ended today she tells us is a
good day no shelling only machine gun
fire
i go on walks with the kids around the
village and we hear machine gun fire in
the distance we just do our thing we're
not scared
katya's three children have grown up
knowing nothing but conflict now as
all-out war seems ever more likely she's
weeks away from giving birth to a fourth
she knows most people couldn't imagine
bringing up a family in a place like
this
for better or worse this is my village
i know all the paths i know where to
hide if the bombing starts
i know what will protect me
if i can drop into a ditch in time i'll
survive
after sticking it out for years even is
now making plans to leave
back at the front lines i ask alexander
if he thinks russia will get its way and
keep ukraine out of western alliances
nato membership is not going to happen
anytime soon but i think in the end
they'll take us a lot has changed in
this country and so have we the russians
have done everything they could to
convince us that they're not our
brothers to make us turn our backs on
them
and for now at least russia seems to be
in no mood to try to win back ukrainian
hearts and minds
you